i think the movie's about uh
two things i think it's about a a
sort of a fantasy of a woman who has an
idea of what hollywood is and what she's
sort of going to become
um and then it's a love story on top of
it
this is the girl i want to say
about i guess that hollywood dream
i don't talk about um
things like that you see the film and
you um
feel and think your way through just
like any other film and you come up with
conclusions
um
it's beautiful to go into
uh a new world and that's what cinema
gives us a chance to do he actually has
one of the healthiest attitudes about
l.a
and hollywood than
anyone i've ever known but having said
that this is a guy
who loves la as much as he does but he
doesn't really leave his house much i'm
so lucky to find both these
girls and justin thoreau and and the
whole cast you try to get the right
person for the part everyone who is
known
was at one point unknown so i think uh
these particular you know actors um
have a chance to become known they've
got the stuff
and drive
that's where i was going
david loves uh los angeles and hollywood
i don't necessarily think this is his
take on it i think this is his take of a
sort of a weak-minded person's take on
hollywood many of the things on the
surface exist the directors producers
studio heads you know these kinds of
things but they all exist in this sort
of demented non-real way you know like
the studio head is this sort of bizarre
you know man who lives underneath with
curtains and you know
behind glass with a little earpiece and
those kinds of things you know which are
really sort of like sort of how the
studio system exists in your
subconscious you know that they have
this incredible power to shut things
down turn things on
you know and manipulate people and and
sort of wreck and change their lives
is that something you might agree with
sure
people have been getting off the bus for
years and years
and i say it's like going to las vegas
everybody goes there
thinking they got a chance to win and
they all do have a chance to win but 99
of them come back with less than they
went in with and he's also i think very
attached to
this the old hollywood mythology
meaning you know like all the movies
that we saw growing up
especially for him in the in the 50s
and i think that's how he sees it
perhaps through rose-colored glasses but
there's a few things that um he sends up
and and i don't think it's the way he
sees it but you know obviously it's done
with a lot of irony and it makes it fun
that girl is not in my film
it's no longer your film
i live in new york but in in los angeles
it's
five thousand times worse for an actor
because i i mean i'm actually always
contending people tell you to be sort of
tough to live in new york i disagree
it's the opposite you have to be really
tough to live in los angeles because
that town on a
continual basis just crushes your
feelings you know you just feel terrible
all the time in los angeles right i do i
mean that's something to do with my sort
of state of mind but
it
it's a continual feeling hurt
you know if you will